[Applaudissements]
choisir faire les choix les grands les
petits nous en faisons tous les jours
quoi manger midi quelle ruse prendre
pour éviter les bouchons ouest et à la
bibliothèque quelques heures de plus et
avalé les stickers et les chips ou
rentrer maintenant manger correctement
travailler plus tard ne pouvant plus
espérer que chaque choix est fait
librement
peu importe son ampleur mais est ce que
c'est vraiment le cas
combien de fois son menu confrontés à
des situations où nous pensons qu'une
n'avons pas de choix
nous n'avons pas d'autres options mais
de prendre une ligne de conduite
particulière c'est juste comme ça c'est
ce qu'on attend de nous peut-être ce
sont les forces externes qui nous dit ça
le travail qui le veut
le dynamique de groupe o peut-être ce
sont les forces internes les rêves que
nous avons créée pour nos propres vies
les règles qui vient peut-être de
l'enfance de l'adolescence de nos profs
de nos parents et qui sont renforcés
avec l'âge et l'expérience mais peu
importe que ce soit les forces internes
qu'externes face à ces situations nous
faisons ce qui est attendu
nous suivons les règles nous faisons
plaisir à tout le monde parce que nous
croyons que nous n'avons pas le choix
donc nous ne choisissons pas mais le
problème avec les choix c'est le simple
fait de ne pas choisir c'est quand même
un choix et qu'on ne choisit sont une
chose
nous écartons forcément autre chose et
concède autre chose c'est nous-mêmes et
notre propre bien-être et quand nous
faisons cela pendant des années ça peut
devenir dangereux moi en tant que
fiscaliste j'ai passé toute une carrière
a choisi une chose le bulot et à cartes
et autres choses moi-même et mon bien
être et je peux vous dire qu'à un moment
donné il est devenu critique
je suis juriste formation ancien
fiscaliste et pendant des années je me
réveille tous les matins on remplit de
bonheur parce que j'allais retrouver un
environnement stimulant passionnant
créative l'environnement de fiscalistes
dans un cabinet de conseil en
l'apparence je suis devenue la
définition de succès la femme de
confiance pour mes patrons mes clients
mes clips celle qui allait résulte les
problèmes avec des solutions innovantes
et en tant que femme expérimentée dans
mon équipe
un modèle pour les autres femmes de
département et pour faire cela pour
devenir cette définition de succès j'ai
travaillé des heures les nuits les week
end les vacances mais au delà des
apparences derrière cette façade ma vie
commençait à s'effondrer petit à petit
faust est toujours obligé est la plus
forte ne jamais montrer de faiblesse ne
jamais demander de l'aide
parce que je croyais que j'avais pas le
droit de demander de l'aide
donc je travaillais et je commençais
m'épuiser mais je me sentais piégé parce
que je croyais que cet épuisement ça
faisait partie de la réussite que deux
réussi en tant que fiscaliste à veules
et forcément dire sacrifie ma vie
personnelle sufrir est en toujours en
compétition parce que c'est ce que j'ai
vu quand j'étais jeune c'est ce que j'ai
vu renforcé par des années d'expérience
dans un cabinet de conseil donc je
travaillais et quand les choses
devenaient difficiles je travaillais
encore plus parce qu'en fait je savais
pas faire autrement je ne savais pas
comment me ralentir prends soin de moi
ou inspirait moi je savais travail et
donc j'ai continué à choisir le travail
payait quartier moi même et mon
bien-être prendre des années jusqu'à ce
que je m'épuise complètement j'ai fait
un burn ait une fois deux fois et en
il fallait vraiment que je reprenne
contrôler tout ça que je commence à
prendre soin de moi mais pour le faire
il fallait un vrai électrochoc
à l'époque j'avais l'impression de
toujours marcher dans la boue dans une
monde où quelqu'un avait aspiré tu dois
joies de la planète
je me réveille tous les matins on
remplit n'ont pas de bonheur mais
dongguan donc coincé deux peurs peur que
les autres voient ce que moi je voyais
derrière cette façade de succès que
j'étais un poster j'étais nul j'étais
bon à rien j'étais en pleine période
pour le deuxième fois et j'étais scotché
dans mon canapé je voulais pas me lever
me laver ni manger ni sortir et surtout
je ne venais pas demander de l'aide mais
le 6 mars 2014 j'ai eu mon déclic
c'était le jour des funérailles d'un
collègue peter et c'est le jour où j'ai
choisi de vivre à l'âge de 67 ans puis
tu es décédé subitement et j'ai assisté
à ses funérailles
c'était un gentleman et un gentilhomme
et il était hors de question que j aie
pas donc je suis allé à ses funérailles
même si ça voulait dire sortie de mon
pyjama pour la première fois depuis des
siècles et pendant les funérailles je me
rendais compte quelque chose pictures il
n'est pas mort suite à une simple crise
cardiaque
il s'était suicidé il a passé le week
end avec ses amis a rigolé à plaisanter
et le lundi matin et s'est levé il s'est
rendu au pont rouge au luxembourg et la
soute et pendant les funérailles les
choses qui m'ont le plus marqué c'était
les témoignages de ses amis
on aurait pu être là ils disaient
pourquoi il n'a rien dit
ce qui est évident c'est le tristesse
mais aussi la confusion il avait passé
du temps avec lui quelques heures
auparavant mais n'a rien dit ambühl est
en fait il voulait pas qu'ils voient ce
qu'ils vivaient ils voulaient pas qu'il
souffrait de cette grande dépression
donc il n'a rien dit et quand je suis
remonté dans la voiture c'est ce jour là
j'ai commencé à pleurer mon coeur s'est
brisé à l'âge de 67 ans pitch croyez
qu'il n'avait pas de choix
il vivait une enfermé pouvaient pas
parler avec ses amis aient pensé qu'il
pouvait pas demander de l'aide
donc il a fait la seule chose qui
pouvait échapper à cet enfer et la
soutient et à ce moment là le 6 mars
assise au volant de ma voiture j'ai pris
une décision
j'ai pris une décision que sa vie à lui
sera pas la mienne son futur non plus
j'avais des amis et pourrait aider mais
ils n'étaient pas de vains donc j'ai
pris mon courage dans les deux mains
j'ai pris mon téléphone et j'ai dû j'ai
appelé et pour la première fois de ma
vie j'ai demandé de l'aide
depuis ce jour là depuis ces presque
cinq ans je me suis relevé j'ai repensé
ma vie et mes choix
tout d'abord il fallait dormir mais
après il fallait retrouver mes amis et
me rappeler que j'étais pas tout seul
j'ai découvert le yoga le méditer le
méditation et plus important encore j'ai
vraiment fait une grande réflexion ce ce
qui était important dans ma vie qu'est
ce que je voulais faire ou ne pas faire
et après 16 ans en fiscalité
j'ai décidé qu'il avait plus dans la vie
que les déclarations fiscales
aujourd'hui je suis entrepreneur je fais
quelque chose qui m'inspire tous les
jours et je le fais à mon rythme en à
moi non par le rythme imposé par les
autres alors est-ce que c'est facile
tous les jours
non il y a les jours où ses forces
internes les règles que j'ai créée pour
ma vie ils ont du mal à partir
et je vais me culpabiliser parce que je
suis pas en train de travailler 10 à 12
heures par jour mais qu aux mondiaux
aujourd'hui je suis arrivé à un stade ou
dans ma vie ma santé et mon bien être ce
sont les choix les plus importants que
je fais tous les jours
alors ne me comprenait pas mal ce n'est
pas une question de devenir feignante ni
de devenir égoïste c'est pas question
d'un moi moi moi non mais c'est une
question de sommeil
de limite est de savoir que je suis
meilleur atout si je suis épuisée et
crevé je suis bon à rien et à personne
depuis ces cinq dernières années j'ai
également parlé avec d'autres personnes
qui ont passé par là je leur ai parlé de
le combat face à l'épuisement
professionnel et de la victoire parce
que ce qui est certain pour ces
personnes c'est que ces dames victoire
ils ont gagné une bataille
ils ont eu du sang déclic un jouet vous
ont choisi ils se sont choisi eux-mêmes
ils ont laissé de côté la nécessité de
toujours plaints aux autres ils ont eu
un déclic pour lancer un accident de
moto un autre c'était un décès au bureau
d'un collègue pour une troisième c'était
le jour où s'est rendu compte qu'elle
était tellement épuisée qu'elle ne
savait plus comment faire les spaghettis
polonais ce procès enfants mais peu
importe la raison un jour il y a eu une
choix parce que ce n'est pas suffisant
de vue loin changer les choses il faut
vraiment choisir de les changer
et eux ils ont choisi est comme moi des
hommes et comprennent les avantages du
sommeil du repos pour se montrer la
meilleure version de soi même au monde
non pas une version simplifiée simplifie
parce qu'on est tellement crever qu'il
faut lutter pour survivre à une journée
mais est-ce que tu ça c'est facile on
now ce n'est pas facile pour plusieurs
raisons tout d'abord parce que suivant
on se rend même pas compte qu'on est en
train de se dire qu'on n'a pas de choix
parce que c'est comme si on suit un
programme de pilote automatique
deuxième au mans deuxième raison il est
allé moment où quand on est en train de
se dire on n'a pas de choix c'est
vraiment ça a l'impression de on a
l'impression que c'est vraiment une
question de vie ou de mort
la réaction dans le corset physique et
troisièmement si nous sommes vraiment
honnête de ne choisir nous-mêmes et
notre bien-être ses deux enfants ou
reprendre responsabilités pour nos vies
et nos destins
et c'est de mettre de côté la
possibilité de rester en posture de
victime d'une vie donc non ce n'est pas
facile mais ça peut être appris et
j'aimerais partager avec vous ce que moi
j'ai appris à faire
tout d'abord c'est de constater et
entendez les moments où vous êtes en
train de vous dire je n'ai pas de choix
quelles sont les situations où ce
réflexe vns qu'il est un père tual
là-dedans
deuxièmement on respire et ne vue cassé
par la tête du simple fait d'avoir son
réflexe parce qu'il est là depuis des
années
il faut simplement le voir et
troisièmement décider ce que vous voulez
vraiment faire remettre en cause ce
réflexe est ce que c'est vraiment vrai
que vous n'avez pas de choix capoue est
un deuxième option une troisième option
et arrêtez-vous et des silices que vous
voulez vraiment faire
alors oui peut-être que vous allez faire
ce qui est attendu de vous parce qu'il
ya les situations que vous allez faire
mais au moins cette fois-ci vous
reprenez contrôle de vos choix et vu le
fait parce que vu le vul est vraiment et
peut-être vous allez prendre un autre
chemin
est-ce que tu ça c'est facile
non mais ça peut être appris je le
savais pas à l'époque mais je le sais
aujourd'hui
et en plus ce que je sais aujourd'hui
c'est ce que je voudrais pour vous ici
dans cette salle
aujourd'hui c'est eu d'abord de faire
vos choix en pleine conscience
deuxièmement c'est de savoir que vous
n'avez pas besoin d'attendre ce que tu
ta vie s'écroule pour commencer à
choisir et troisièmement pour ceux
d'entre vous qui sont les étudiants ici
à m6 et de l'antique et même les profs
ont respiré
c'est vrai vous avez survécu au cours
préparatoire au stress du concours et
maintenant que vous êtes ici à m6 et de
l'antique ça ne lâche pas il faut
toujours être performant se montrait
motivé créer son propre réseau trouver
le bureau points après faire des pitchs
écrire les papiers fait les examens et
tout et tout et tout et ça ne lâche pas
mais hospira parce que sinon vous êtes
en train d'apprendre et de renforcer les
habitudes que plus tard pour illuminer
un burn-out
je peux vous dire que personne ne
commence une carrière en se disant
susceptibles de faire un peu long mais
ça arrive beaucoup plus souvent qu'on
aurait comme pourrait penser donc
inspiré même si c'est seulement pour 5
minutes vous allez pas en relative aux
examens ou et demi à la porte simplement
parce que vous avez pris cinq minutes
cinq minutes pour espérer et rechange et
un peu vos batteries en fait au
contraire vous serez sans doute beaucoup
plus efficace et beaucoup plus productif
éviter un peu un an et potentiels ne
qu'elle n'est qu'une seul exemple de ce
qui peut arriver si vous prenez contrôle
de vos choix et si vous prenez contrôle
de vos choix et vu vous choisissez vous
même tous les jours à partir
d'aujourd'hui
imaginez la vie que vous pourriez vivre
merci
[Applaudissements]